ryan
jose steve ty david joseph
sarah's still with us eric chloe
john who am i talking to everyone i'll
be moderating tom how are you it's good
to see you again
nice to see you
first of all i wanted to congratulate
you one extraordinary movie
um thank you so much i know i think
i hope so too i think it's an
extraordinary film said in
post-civil war american west that i feel
is very relevant today
it talks about healing it talks about
searching for home
i like to think of it as the mandalorian
without lightsabers
[Laughter]
well before we start the press
conference i just want to remind
everyone that
news of the world opens in theaters on
december 25th and on demand for in-home
digital rental from
january 15 onwards and um
i'll start with a question for you tom
being someone who i believe chooses his
projects
uh very carefully and as shown that way
over the years i'm sure there were many
reasons to do this film
but what were your reasons when i read
uh
paul giles book um there were two things
first of all the the actual
job itself the the the news reader the
guy who traveled from
town to town uh to uh
enlighten and connect an audience in you
know diverse
small towns you know wichita falls what
have you
um i thought that was that's a job that
i would have wanted to have if i had
been
if i had been alive in the in the 1870s
i thought that would be fascinating
um not because you'd be delivering both
the service and
also sort of like you you'd be
delivering a um
a connectivity that people wouldn't have
look everybody wants to belong to
something bigger than themselves
sometimes that's just being a member of
an audience but the enlightenment that
would come along
from stories big and small how wonderful
the world could be and also how
dangerous it is
in our film you know one of the first
thing he talks about is a disease that
is killing people you know how many
souls have been lost
we didn't know we didn't quite realize
we were going to be uh
you know ripped right out of the front
pages of covet 19 we were talking about
something else though
it was very real at the time it was
important to know
other stories that he talked about is
you know railroads that are going to be
improving their lines
how high the river is and whether bridge
is isolated and or not
it's not so much in the film but it's
still there there's other places where
we talk about queen elizabeth in the
brooklyn bridge and the uh
and the cincinnati reds baseball club
um that is uh uh
that's kind of like for the subject of
emotion picture that character and that
job
i think is sort of like beautifully
uh internally cinematic telling a story
as you tell a story is inherently i
think powerful and engaging
that's one aspect of it the other part
was how many
how often it happened and how common it
was in american history
for native american tribes to make rates
and take away
young children and to raise them uh in
the ways of their
of their tribe in this case uh the kiowa
it happened
very very frequently and as uh as she
mentions i think
uh in either the introduction or the
afterwards of her book
the bath a large majority of those uh
of those children that we're taking uh
wanted to return to their
their indian ways uh that sound that's
extraordinary that that speaks to you
know the nurturer versus nature argument
that i think is is something that we
would all identify with somehow what
happened
what would what would we have thought if
we had been those kids or if we had been
the parents of those kids
so um right then and there it i think it
was a very very unique movie there's not
an awful lot of westerns that are made
anymore
um uh uh and i
i think for reasons but this actually um
what we're gonna be doing with this
movie was contrary to an awful lot of
the way
western movies work and that is all the
problems are solved by gun play yes
there is a
clumsy kind of like gun fight that
happens in this thing but it's not
particularly
um it's not uh glamorous it's actually
kind of like
odd and it happens almost by
mistakes and the rest of it is about
people engaging
in uh in what their lives are so i
thought we had a shot here uh
of making dare we call it a unique
motion motion picture that
even though it is quote unquote the
genre of a western
that really is only communicated by the
fact that we ride on horses and we're
outside a lot
i think the rest of it is uh is very uh
is very accessible
thank you tom uh ryan you had a question
yeah hey tom i'm ryan with amc theaters
hi so that's kind of my question to you
too
is what has taken you so long to enter
the western genre
and what was it about news of the world
that made that this movie
well nobody makes westerns i mean it's
as simple as that i mean
you know if you want to look at the you
know the business i know of westerns
that have been made that had
absolutely no uh international
distribution deals
because it just felt as their audiences
don't don't relate to westerns
the idea of a western the genre of the
western kind of like the storytelling
device
if you took john ford well now it's all
you know john ford has been lucasized
george lucas uh the science fiction
movie has really taken the concept of
the western away you know
blasters and lightsabers instead of bows
and arrows and six guns
um you know uh snow speeders as opposed
to horses
that's not a bad thing that's that's
just that that's just the way
you know the way cinema works
the other thing that goes into it why
haven't why haven't they been
you know what what's the scoop of the of
the demise
quote-unquote of the western well i
don't know that
you know clint eastwood still makes them
on occasion and they're powerful
the cohen brothers made a magnificent uh
the ballot of buster scruggs that had
inside it
probably five or six really great
western stories in it
but um the i i think the bigger question
is here is
is is it is it the is it the time period
and the style or the story itself
um a movie i think has if you're going
to make a western
it has to need to be a western in order
to be
in order to have impact um it it
you know and i think i think this is
demonstrated by the fact that people
in our movie people pay 10 cents to find
out
about queen elizabeth and their lives
are are
hugely impacted by the time they spend
listening to captain kidd
there's a line in the film that i think
kind of like lays out the entire
logic of the movie in which captain kidd
says to johanna and she doesn't even
understand it but he says it's going to
take us six days six days to get from
here to there
that means they can only traverse
geography as fast as a horse can walk
unless unless there's some other
contrivance that is put into it in order
to in order to impede the progress of
the characters
in modern times the western turns out to
be
the best way in order to enforce a movie
to operate
upon that that timeline so
uh you know i think it's like how can we
have it made of western it's like people
could say i'd really like to make
a western in the same same way they'd
say i'd really like to make a movie
about irish coal miners
but unless the story about irish coal
miners is actually going to have some
important impact there's no reason to
make it likewise there's no reason to
make a western just because you get to
wear comfortable clothes and a hat
it has to be about something that's uh
that's bigger than just the uh
what's the word i'm looking for the
genre of the film or the style of the
film
so um i in all honesty i don't know that
there have been westerns that have come
across the transom
in order to make this might have been
the first one
that ever became a possible story
to do because um why make a western if
you can tell the story in a different
way
you have to you have to decide that that
a movie set in a time period has to be
set in a time period for a specific
reason
okay thank you steve's thematic
hey this is steve weintraub with
collider um i think that the
i think we can all agree that the movie
industry right now is going through a
seismic shift
and um movie theaters are in trouble um
and uh i'm curious for your on your
thoughts
do you think that movie theaters are are
gonna survive
and if so are they just gonna be event
pictures
all right let's where do you where do
you live steve i'm just curious
los angeles where movie theaters have
been yeah
right okay even in los angeles it's a
bit hard to go to the movies isn't it
it's you gotta drive you gotta park uh
you gotta be there at a very certain
time i mean i love the arc light there's
one in
hollywood there's one not too far away
from where i live
um there's also a theater that was open
that was charging 27
a seat so then people could would bring
you the nachos and they didn't even have
a snack bar that you could stand in line
you had to pay 27 dollars
and you had to order from somebody which
means as you're watching rocket man as i
did
somebody comes by and says can i get you
some more cheese on your nachos
no i'm good man i'm just watching the
movie i paid 27
there are there's there's there is this
reality
of of uh
the viability of of exhibiting movies
that is that has been based on the
desire of people to see the movie now in
new york city where i am right now
i think new york is one of the easiest
places to go to the movies
you can decide to go to the movies and
be in the theater a half hour later
you can walk to one you know there's
enough screens around when
when the movies are open of course that
you can go off and can actually have a
plethora of choices
even though those choices might only be
the 12 movies that are playing
you know nationally at any given time
this goes a long way to say that a sea
change was due anyway
um it was coming um the fact is
that there is let me okay i don't want
to take up too much time on this answer
but let me tell let me tell you this
story
when i was a kid and the abc
sunday night movie played the first half
of david lean's bridge over the river
kwai
in pannin scan in 133
with commercials i was still convinced
that the bridge over the river kwai was
one of the greatest motion pictures i
had ever seen
and it was as primitive a display as
possible
it might have even been in black and
white i don't think we had a colored
television the first time it was on
and he had to watch it the second time
uh that he had to watch the second half
on monday night the school night
that didn't take away from my enjoyment
of bridge over the river quad
i didn't even know that there was
limitations on it
now we're of course with netflix and all
the streaming services
we have we have the ability to sit and
watch a movie anytime we want to on our
couch
if the movie is really great and
engaging you can still come away from
that experience thinking that was one of
the greatest motion pictures i have ever
seen
i've experienced that just recently with
chernobyl uh the five part thing i said
i
i that was one of the greatest motion
pictures i've ever seen and it comes
across on some other
other films as well will movies
movie theaters still exist absolutely
they will
in some ways uh i think the exhibitors
once they're once they're up and open
are going to have a freer choice of what
movies they do want to play
but i'm going to uh i'm and i'm no
cassandra when it comes down to this but
i'm going to say that
big event motion pictures are going to
rule the day at the cinemas
um there's a type of film that is about
you know
it could even be the case the
news of the world might be the last kind
of like adult movie about people saying
interesting things
that's going to play on a big screen
somewhere because after this
in order to guarantee that people show
up again we're going to have the marvel
universe and all sorts of franchises
and some of those movies are great you
want to see them um
writ large because actually uh
watching it at home on your couch
actually might diminish them somewhere
somehow uh in in their in their in their
visual punch
but the sea change that has been
wrought by covid19 has been a slow
train coming i think there will be an
awful lot of movies that will only be
streamed
and it will be fine to see them that way
because they're actually
built and made and constructed for
somebody's pretty you know pretty good
screen widescreen tv at their home and
there will be other movies
that are going to be playing in that
window uh and
people will in fact i think flock to
them in order to see them on the big
screen while they
while they have the chance but without a
doubt um
we are we're we are actually into the
the big curve of change
um that's uh that i think has been due
ever ever since people uh you know
first had the ability to what is it
called pvod pain
pay for video on demand ever since that
started up actually it probably mean you
can maybe
argue ever since the vhs cassette tape
um
uh was first introduced in a cheap way
um this is uh this has been uh this has
been
just across the horizon i don't think
that answers your question though
it definitely does chloe great hi chloe
with e talk out of toronto
we are such big fans in canada
congratulations on your film
thanks you know captain kid is somebody
with a real
love for storytelling and it's clear
that you are as well but i'm curious how
did your storytelling over
four toy story films was my favorite
cowboy woody
help prepare you for captain kids
western journey
oh not a bit not a wit not a single
single thing in common whatsoever
absolutely
absolutely none nothing
you know the toy story movies um
you know the thing that's extraordinary
is that we made the first one over 25
years ago
i don't know if there's a lot of people
movies that have the
same same people involved you know from
25 years ago the great thing is is that
you know animated toys don't age
so you don't see them slowing down or
or or uh you know getting older
um but there you know the the the i i
guess
the the there's a way of looking at it
i don't know if i don't know if anybody
can can can truly grasp this
but in fact no movie translates to the
next movie you're making
you start all over from from scratch
now granted you you know how things work
you know how you know how camera you
know how a set works you know about
base camp and you know about the
difference between shooting on film and
you learn how you learn you learn
technique you learn the technical
aspects
of making movies but the movie that you
made
last year or five years ago or 25 years
ago does not
impact the emotional journey that you're
on i don't know
you start all over again from scratch
and that's why so many actors are stark
or even nuts
is because they uh uh they are always
thrown up onto this
this high wire without a net uh and
uh you if you make a mistake or if
you're not if you don't get there let me
put it that way
if you as an artist and a creative
entity in a
and an interpreter of uh somebody else's
words if you don't
get there where you need to be
you will not get there for the rest of
time because the movie
is locked it lasts forever and you you
can't go back
and and change it so uh coming into the
news of the world
it was it was literally it was like how
how i i never feel as though
i know what i'm doing on a movie until
day three of shooting i wander around in
a confused stupor saying
is this any good is this right does this
make any sense
uh have we started this right are you
actually going to use what we shot
yesterday
because i don't think i had it so so in
order in order to get there you just
have to have some brand of
foolhardy faith uh in in
in in your abilities and and also trust
in
everybody else that's there to to help
you pull along and i will tell you
that um news of the world had helena's
angle not been attached to my
hip for this time um it would i
it would have been i don't know how we
would have gotten there we would not
have had a movie without her in this
it's it it it it's not enough to say we
had to cast the perfect
child actor in this movie the if that
that
that also that turns it into like a you
know a process
as as opposed to uh um finding
somebody who could just be johanna
um the the way she wore cicada as uh as
the way she had to be we we didn't
we didn't act we didn't work on this
movie we were just
we were we were just the movie we just
behaved throughout the course of the
movie
uh and we we had give and take we
we we talked about everything under the
sun including you know
what what we're going to do which
happened to make a movie
during the same day that that we spent
together
that alone is a brand new unique
experience that um i didn't know was
going to happen until
until it started up so you the only the
only way you can go
into this is to you jump out of a plane
and you hope that you had a parachute on
because you might have forgotten it it's
terrifying but
it is terrifying
it is terrifying eric how's it going sir
eric eisenberg
thank you so much for taking the time
today uh this is kind of actually a
follow-up to that uh to your answer not
intended as but i'm curious just about
your opportunity
working with paul greengrass again
because this is your second time after
working on captain phillips
it is a radically different film but
what is also notable
about paul greengrass's involvement is
he is a journalist he's a documentarian
and i'm curious just about the influence
that that had on the experience
other than the whole free fall out
without a parachute part
well that the paul makes these movies
that are about exp
or experiential you know he he does not
you he uses an observational camera not
a subjective one he certainly did on on
on uh captain phillips and the
the way we worked on captain phyllis was
truly about procedure and behavior
um i mean there's a script and there's a
story without a doubt it but all of that
stuff has to happen in a real
universe on a real ship and on on on the
real sea
so a lot of a lot of what we were doing
uh was based on truly the physical
universe that we were living in news of
the world is different because it does
have lighting it does have the
presentational telling of the stories it
does have performances inside it
um and it does have the artifice of you
know outside and
horses opposed to cars and there's no
there's no
absolutely no modern conveniences so in
that in that regard um
paul uh the day
let me tell you this story the first day
that we
shot um the telling of the news the the
first
the first news performance uh the first
uh drop in a dime and good evening hello
ladies and gentlemen captain jefferson
kyle kidd and i would like to share the
news of the world with you
let us start with you know how many
people are dead of cholera
um we were halfway through the shooting
day and we
ended up sitting on the wooden sidewalk
of one of our western towns
and we went at it he and i about what
these performances of readings of the
news
meant and i was hell-bent
on authenticity and the real news
and the real stories and almost of a
a dry perspective and presentation of
them
and he was bent on
on the connecting of the audience of the
inspiring of the audience and the
reading of the audience
and of the enthronement of the audience
with what this news was and
we actually we went like this for a bit
because he was saying you you must
understand
you are putting on a show to bring
people together
and i was saying paul you've got to
understand i am reading the news
to bring people together and we had to
find
this thing that was in there and that i
think that's that's
a bit different from the previous
experience that paul and i had
now inside that was this
new combination of paul's lighting and
darius walski's you know cinematography
that did require you know light
reflecting off the water and hitting
marks and
you know the horizon lines and not
shooting until golden hour and things
like that
which was contrary to what we had done
on you know on
on the captain phillips stick so it was
quite a uh
i wasn't i i can't say i anticipated
the two you know grand areas of uh of
territory that he was ex
he was exploring as a filmmaker and i
couldn't speak to that
but to me as an actor in a paul
greengrass movie i was experiencing
brand new territory as well
that uh that uh took me a little bit by
uh by surprise but ended up being you
know the
it's the best kind of loggerheads to be
in when you're making a movie
because you're arguing about how to best
get
to the same desired place and that is
what is it about what captain kidd is
doing with the news
that is in both enthralling and
enlightening and
encompassing uh that audience
it was uh again there was no there was
no preparation for it
it was just a matter of getting up and
uh and pounding it
of getting there never easy
david daniel has a question thank you
hi tom david daniels uh as jose cnn
at the beginning it's not difficult to
look at this film
set in 1870 and see echoes of
our modern political and and social
divide
how aware of that were you at the time
and was it something that you and paul
deliberately played up or
did you just let the similarities speak
for themselves uh
paul was i think dead set on
understanding it um you know we we made
this a year before that we started this
a year
before the election um and we knowing
that the election was coming up
um his uh uh the conversation i had i
learned
to speak on my side because if you guys
get to talk to paul you talk to paul
he was saying look there's a reason for
this divide
um we were our movie was set just right
right after the civil war so there was a
sense of loss
in texas there was a sense of loss to a
cause there was it's
an adverse change was in the air that
was being wrought upon
these people against their will they
didn't like it
and yet here was this guy who was going
to come down
and report on such things as who the
president of the united states was
ulysses s grant
you know he was he was um
he was sensitive i think to
the fact to the to to the thin theme
that
uh captain kidd was bringing the truth
to a group of people that did not want
to accept it
he did not want to accept that truth and
you know we we kind of went round and
round about
you know how vocal you know there's one
scene where reading kind of like goes
off the rails because of what goes on
and we would uh we'd have to moderate
well you know
what's captain kidd's role here is is he
to editorialize is he to tell
you know uh is he to put things in a
binary kind of form it's either a one or
it's a zero and you
you just don't think you could do it or
is there some other
editorial aspect of it almost a
commentary aspect to put forth hey hey
hey
we're all in this together and i know
times are tough and we all have a lot
that we have to get
we all have to get through um that ended
up being much more prescient holy cow
uh then we were i think you know we're
not we're not seers we can't see into
the future we didn't know what was
what was coming down the pike but
they're they're
paul as a as a filmmaker and as the the
journalist said he us
he was he was seeing um he saw the
reasons for he saw
sort of like the the groundswell of
motivations
where as i as the actor who was playing
captain kidd i was looking at it as
almost from the
potential of well let's stay in the
present not let's not deal with the past
paul was you know paul was always
thinking about understand what these
people have been through
understand what they've suffered
understand what they've lost including
you
captain jefferson kid and i was always
saying
well we have here we are we have to we
have to stay in the moment we have to
tell the truth that we have to
uh be looking to to where we're going to
be going tomorrow
as opposed to be bitter about why we
were yesterday
um that was also comes i think from from
paulette giles's uh
uh book which i think is magnificent
that
that paul is a filmmaker wanted to say i
think it's odd
and it's also kind of like the power of
the cinema that here we are
you know we made a movie that takes
place in 1870 and it speaks to 20
20 20. you know um ate that the movies
in a nutshell
that you can see this uh see a film that
is about people riding horses and it's
like
wow that's really speaking about what
it's like today i think we're all going
through something like that
how how about how about that and there's
uh outside of uh
a fake river uh there ain't a single
special effects in the in this movie
other than uh
we weren't really beside the rio grande
so that says something to the
power of the cinema thank you tom ty
hi tom thai character and apple tv okay
uh in this uh this film aims to get
every detail right in recreating the
period including enlisting the help of
indigenous
uh tribal elders linguists and the other
thirty actors what was it like working
with the oklahoma kiowa nation
um the day that we actually shot with a
kiowa nation
um they were more or less
in the background of a very important
sequence
and they were representative of
something that they themselves had
actually gone through
we we didn't have native americans who
were playing
generic native americans we had the
kiowa nation
playing the kiowa nation it was
important
to us that they were there and i think
it had
weight to them that they were part of
the process
i mean in the book we it specifically
says kiowa
um and in the movie we specifically had
the kiowa there
that they were um we had a we had a
number of
uh chances to to talk
um and chat and we met uh i met uh
you know literally some of the elders
that are the last remaining
native speakers of it that are passing
along literally the language on to those
who want to learn the language that are
that are in the tribe um and
uh when they uh we
we had a few moments when we were
shooting and
it by the way it wasn't it was old folks
it was young folks
it was they were they we we had people
that we had
members of the chiron nation that were
13 years old eight years old that were
around there
so it was multi-generational um
and they said we would like to we would
like to see you
a song of celebration that um
that hess that has been sung for
hundreds of years
amongst our people at moments like this
and moments of import
or moments of notoriety and um
as they sang it um they brought tears to
their eyes because
it's not just something it's not
something that they did lightly
it was it was intrinsically connected
into their dna and to a history that is
longer
than white people's history of the
united states of america
um and what was extraordinary i think in
many ways is that there was not a there
was not a degree of bitterness there was
not a degree of anger
uh uh there was instead like uh
it was like an inclusion that was
offered up to us
that uh simply said you know um i think
we appreciate
that you're not taking this story
lightly that you're not taking our role
in this
lightly which i think in a lot of ways
can be contrary to the way
motion pictures work where they kind of
like sweep in and they get their story
and and uh and they sweep out it was
powerful now
is it something that is something that
is um
that is evident in our film or or is it
just something that we keep in our
pocket
as well we had that it doesn't matter
really just the fact that it's there is
uh
is uh has value all into it so whether
it's important or not
whether uh it you know trends uh where
it's
connected to uh other other audience
members uh
know of it and appreciate isn't nearly
as important of the fact that
um paul and the team and us as
filmmakers put it there in the first
place
and and made it not just a priority but
the priority for the uh for the entire
movie it had to be the kiowa
and we had to have the kiowa do it for
us
and last but not least joseph you had a
question
yes hello mr hanks uh first of all
congratulations
the film amazing job um the question i
have is uh
what what intrigued you the most about
captain kidd and what was it that you
wanted to bring to the character that
wasn't necessarily found on the page
whether it be in the novel or in the
script
he is an extremely haunted man by his
entire life
uh and you get it uh you find out the
specifics of it when you read paulette
giles book
um for i'm not i i i rail against
backstory uh in a lot of in a lot of
films because i think it can
can be reduced to just kind of like a
cinematic tool
as opposed to something that an
intrinsic part
of uh of the narrative and i don't think
you you must never short change the
narrative and if you
you got to make it a little harder then
make it a little harder for crying out
loud
why why uh why take shortcuts um
paul was huge on
um the the history of
you know his civil war understand
captain kidd fought for the south
for texas whether he believed in or not
didn't matter
um it was he and he went off and he saw
horrible things
he did horrible things he was a younger
man then actually wasn't that younger
because
our movie you know was only like 15
years prior
or 10 years prior what he did and it
cost him his life it cost him his family
to cost him his wife
not because of uh any overt terror uh
terror uh moment of terror she died of a
disease
and he was gone when it happened and the
reason he was gone was uh with what to
go off and kill people and see more
blood
so the the
paul uh paul said you know he's haunted
you know he's home there's a burden it's
hard to continue along
it's hard and as an actor i say
got it understood yeah hard back story
got it i understand that but how does it
play out
how does it play out right now how does
it play out in the present
of the motion picture um and there was
you know there's there's you know
silence and there's pondering and
people ask them questions about it and
and he and
and he talks about it and i i was uh
whether i whether i told the boss about
this or not
um i was not playing that
um i i was instead playing this question
what do i do tomorrow that's it
i mean how do i keep going tomorrow um
uh i think it's the the journalist in
him that takes in
that takes into the account of
everything that has gone through in the
past
oh here are the signposts of his life
and in the movie and paul at giles you
know he was
he was a messenger uh in the war of 1812
he was a publisher of papers et cetera
he had she
she put together this really beautiful
rich texture
that was complemented by paul's uh
concentrating on his time during the war
and the loss of his wife and i as an
actress said yeah great
got it understood my problem here as
captain
jefferson kyle kidd is how do i get on
the horse and do it again tomorrow
that's that's that's what i'm playing
and the uh
you know the deus ex machina of uh
johanna
or cicada coming into his life that's
the almost like the what's the word i
think that's the serendipity i think
that we all have to have
in order to get on with our lives is
that something's going to come along
some bend in the river is going to show
itself some new thing is going to be
demanded of us that we didn't anticipate
and that is going to be the catalyst
that is going to drive us on
to the next chapter of our lives um
that's what cinema is that's an awful
lot of what of uh you know
the great literature and what narrative
is and and
in the course of uh of news of the world
you have um yeah that not
this isn't the kind of stuff that we
talked about when we were doing it and
yet
it is the kind of stuff like the kiowa
issue this stuff that we have in our
pocket
is that we have a guy who was in his
let's let's say 40s
captain kid let's let's say 42. how hell
do you think captain kid
i'll say 42. i'm gonna say he's 42.
you got a guy who's 42 and you have a
girl that's 10
or 11. and they are in the same exact
place of stasis in their lives
everything they've known is gone they're
on a journey to somewhere else
and they've got to figure out how to get
through tomorrow um
ain't that the human condition in a
nutshell um
uh you know a child that should have
been living carefree and free of all
these burdens instead is burdened with
with how to get on with the rest of her
life and uh captain kidd who should be
living out you know some some better
glory days than he is instead
is thrust into a daily uh daily
existence
that is almost hand to mouth that's
pretty powerful stuff if you can bring
it all together and uh
in one in one uh in one story and it's
not a caper
it's not about a box of money and it's
not about control of the universe and
it's
you know it's not about there is a bad
guy element to it but that's actually
taken care of
like halfway through the movie you know
and in a western
it didn't come down to you know gunfight
at apache pass
or you know a shootout on main street or
the bad guys have arrived on a train
it's about a girl to about getting a
girl home and a guy going home itself
and realizing
that it's neither of those things to
either of either of those characters
that's uh that you know if you can make
that work
you just might have a movie that can
play in movie theaters
until the 15th of january where it's
available on paid
vod and might have people interested in
in participating in it well tom i think
you
you really did make it work thank you
for today thank you all of you for
participating
thanks very much congratulations thank
you nice talking to you all i enjoyed
the questions
we'll do it again